July 13th, 2019.
Scientist Roy Funk is journeying to northern
Brazil.
He's here to investigate something bizarre
revealed from space.
You can't let an opportunity.
Like this pass to see something that's never
been seen in a very real sense.
High over the forests of the Caatinga region,
the GeoEye one satellite captures an expanse
of barren soil recently cleared by ranchers.
You see a semi-arid landscape with some kind
of pock marks.
Almost looks to me like it could have been
bomb craters or some type of holes in the
ground.
Analysts count more than 300 circles across
two patches of scrub.
But zooming in reveals they aren't holes at
all.
It looks like they're not depressions but are
raised areas, mounds of some sort.
When I look at the image, the idea that these
structures could be some type of burial
mounds is plausible.
Giant burial mounds have been discovered
elsewhere in the Amazon dating back as far as
6000 years ago.
If the satellite has revealed an undiscovered
ancient burial site, then its scale is
unparalleled.
It's so vast.
The possibility that they could be burial
mounds is amazing.
Funk is skeptical of the burial mound theory.
There's so many of them.
You know, the burial mounds are usually
reserved for, you know, chiefs and high
priests and rich people.
Yet what they are is hard to tell.
There's nothing like this in the world that I
know of, and I've never heard anything about
them.
The mounds sit in a 386,000 square mile
wilderness known as the White Forest.
What we call cassinga, which is a dry land,
thorny deciduous vegetation that's really
totally intertwined.
You can't see more than 20, 30ft in.
Hey, this should be the spot.
Led by the image coordinates Fudge treks West
seeking signs of the mounds among the thorns
and scrub.
Really hot. It gets sweltering here.
It's in the 90s already here, but it'll get
to 100 quite easily.
I think we're getting near the Mound Fields.
I saw on the satellite images.
This is. This is where they are.
Oh, wow. There we go. There we go.
Mounds.
Wow. Look at that.
Magnificent. These are not burial mounds.
Look how tall they are, how evenly spaced
they are.
It's just another world.
Having reached the site in the satellite
image, Funch doubts these are manmade.
Nor does he believe they are a naturally
occurring feature of the landscape.
It's just actually inconceivable that there
would be a purely geological origin.
The two symmetrical.
There are two. Even the two well space for
me.
They're pretty obviously biogenic, almost
certainly built by some sort of a creature.
And Funsch has suspicions about which
creature.
I'm more pushed toward it being a termite
mound than any other animal that I can think
of. Termites are famous for some of their
huge structures in Africa and Australia.
You get huge termite mounds, very complex
structures taller than this.
But these structures look very different from
termite mounds found elsewhere in the world.
And as Funk explores further, he discovers
that they cover a wider area than he ever
imagined.
Okay. You can see there's a mound over there.
It's quite camouflaged.
One, two, third one over there.
There's no reason why they shouldn't keep on
going.
This farce just goes on and on.
Returning to the satellite image, Funk makes
a staggering discovery.
Not hundreds of mounds, not even thousands,
but millions.
200 million mounds stretching through the
white forest for 90,000mi².
If you zoom out a little bit, you can see the
huge scale that we're talking about.
More than the state of Michigan.
It's unbelievable.
If this is the work of termites, it's easily
the largest colony on earth.
But what baffles Funch is that this land
appears to be lifeless.
I don't see any termite activity.
I haven't seen a lizard or a snake or an ant
or anything crawling around here.
But this is the kind of environment that you
just don't want to be active during the day.
To learn more, Funch waits for dusk.
At night. The White Forest is a hunting
ground for various wild animals.
But Funke's prey is smaller.
Now you have to be quiet when you're looking
for termites.
You have to tread softly because they're
very sensitive to vibrations on the ground.
There's the guys.
Lots of them around here.
Termites are Earth's great survivors.
They were here before the dinosaurs 250
million years ago.
Ah, there's the whole. I found the whole.
See the guy popping in and out.
But there's no building activity.
This seems to be a foraging party rather
than a construction team.
That's a that's a leaf.
They chewed on. They probably have chambers
where they where they store this food for
future.
After several hours observing in the dark,
funk is no closer to understanding the hills
seen from space.
The only way we'll ever know that is if we
come out during the day.
Dig them up. Yeah.
The party continued.
Termite mounds are normally riddled with
ventilation shafts leading to numerous
chambers. At the very heart sits the Royal
Chamber.
Here resides the Queen, one of the most
extraordinary females in all nature.
She can lay 25 eggs a minute for up to 50
years.
Time enough to have a family of 250 million.
Okay.
Is this pure clay?
This is what's under the mound.
But they've hit plain dirt.
We've dug into what appears to be a mound of
dirt.
All right. This is.
They're not living here.